there is outrage this morning in a
community outside
seattle over the fate of two teachers at
a catholic school
english teacher paul danforth and girls
soccer coach michelle beatty
are no longer working at kennedy
catholic high school the school
says they resign but some in the
community including local officials say
they were fired for being gay after both
recently got engaged to their same-sex
partners vlad duties following the story
for us vlad good morning it sounds like
the timing here is making people ask
questions
there are a lot of questions and many in
the community in bearing
are upset saying the incident does not
send a strong message
to the lgbtq community our seattle
affiliate cairo was outside kennedy
catholic school yesterday as danforth
and beatty cleaned out their
desks in a statement to parents last
week the catholic schools said the
teachers
voluntarily resigned their positions a
reason for their resignation was not
given
but two king county council members
weighed in one
claimed the teachers were fired quote
solely because they are gay
he went on to say this is a reminder of
the blatant discrimination that
continues to exist in our community
against members
of the lgbt community another councilman
wrote by forcing the resignations of two
teachers over their sexual orientation
kennedy catholic and the archdiocese of
seattle tell young people
especially lgbtq students at kennedy
is that being lgbtq is wrong
danforth and bd did not comment some
students spoke out supporting the
teachers
i'm just upset like the message that's
being sent
to students that they can't be
comfortable with themselves to our
teachers that
they aren't welcome in our school they
haven't done anything to us
the only thing they've done is give us
love and support
over the weekend someone hoisted a gay
pride flag outside the school in support
but it was reportedly taken down very
quickly
we reached out to kennedy high school
for further comment but we did not
hear back what's especially sad for mr
danforth his father taught at that
school for 39 years he was a teacher
there for five years so he is very
much a part of that well the school says
they resign these council members say
they were forced out
we really need to hear from the two
teachers it sounds like yeah
nice hand from those students so very
much so glad thank you